The IPsec header has an IPsec sequence
number designed to prevent replay.
It is used only if Is used, or the
authentication option in ESP is used.
A sliding window of size n,
which should be at least 32, is used.
That is, although packets
may arrive out of order,
the sequence numbers should be
within the window of size n.
More specifically, when a packet
arrives, if its sequence number is
smaller than the smallest number
of the window, it is rejected.
If the number is greater than
the largest sequence number
of the sliding window,
then the packet is accepted, and
the window it advances
to discover this number.
If the sequence number
falls in the window,
it is checked to see if the sequence
number have been seen before.
If yes, it is also rejected.
If not, it is accepted and the number
is recorded as having been seen.
That's how we reject duplicate packets.